salve a tutti ragazzi allora oggi video
extra questo invito extra nel senso che
oggi nessuno due come sapete tutti for
guys ragazzi e scegli il lunedì e il
giovedì sul mio canale non perdetevi gli
episodi perché sono spettacolari perché
li faccio io come lo è oggi che le navi
è uscito for guys perché volevo farvi
vedere la mappa nuova perché uscita la
nuova mappa su for guys da ieri questo
non sarà un episodio normali for guys
sarà semplicemente un episodio dove
voglio farvi vedere come giocare la
nuova mappa perché l'ho fatta mi
sembrava carino farvi vedere come
funziona come cosa visto che l'ho pure
vinta quei ragazzi quello che state per
vedere è una registrazione che ho fatto
senza riprendermi paghi sto giocando per
i fatti miei
allora ragazze di un subito vedere
sapete ormai che gioco ragazzi anche per
i cacchi i miei applegate schierata io
ci gioco per registrarlo ma per i cavoli
mesi dopo un saluto anche sulla
playstation 3 quando registro registro
sua compiuta ma ci gioca anche sulla
play ad esempio questo mio personaggio
sulla play e ho già vinto tre volte
sulla playstation o tra le varie
vittorie stamattina mi è successo di
vincere sulla nuova mappa ora ve la
faccio vedere perché la nuova app
ragazzi è un minigioco alla fine quindi
è una finale ok va altro ragazzo notato
che con il nuovo aggiornamento arrivi a
45 dopo il primo mini gioco di 40 45 non
più a 30 quindi è molto più difficile
adesso giocherà volgari dopo aver fatto
tutto sto casino ragazzi siamo passati a
bloc party che è sempre il penultimo
minigioco lopardi ragazzi lo dico sempre
rimanete davanti celio la gente davanti
si caga addosso a rimanere perché ha
paura di cadere ma se rimanete dava non
troppo davanti cioè evitate questa linea
qua questa qua evitate sempre che la
linea di un po indietro che sono io
adesso è la gente che sta indietro e
quella che cade non davanti davanti
accade quasi mai nessuno a meno che non
siate dei pirla e vedrete che in tempo
zero poi arriva la qualificazione è
veramente facile secondo me bloc party
poi ci sono alcuni che rimangono sul
cornicione ancora non ho capito come
fanno probe lavori che i ragazzi c'è
stato fall ball che è diventato un
minigioco credo adesso con squadre pari
perché prima non si poteva fare la devo
una squadra con un giocatore in meno era
una merda adesso invece ragazzi hanno
cambiato sta cosa finalmente il
consiglio che do sempre per ball per
quanto non dipenda da voi ma dipende
dalla squadra quindi se la squadra fa
cagare non ci potete fare niente ma
almeno cercate tutti di fare il vostro
meglio sempre qualcuno in difesa
ragazzi sempre qualcuno se non c'è
nessuno in difesa la partita si perde si
perde ora ho visto che c'era un in
difesa quindi sono andati in attacco se
non vedete nessuno andate poi in gol
salvato e con un gol fatto dico sempre
lo ripeterò sempre quando vi cade la
palla nel mezzo come sta facendo questi
la spingete dagli avversari sempre
perché quando fate gol fauna un pallone
nel mezzo quindi ragazzi ricordatevi
questa cosa dopo aver vinto sta partita
come se fosse una finale di champions
league siamo rimasti in 7 e signore e
signori passiamo al momento topico del
video che è jumper showdown che cos'è il
jump showdown ragazzi e il nuovo livello
ed è molto molto simile a quello che già
esiste che praticamente c'è una lancetta
perché immagino appunto sia un orologio
dove la lancetta di sopra la lancetta di
sotto si muovono a velocità diverse con
la differenza che in questo mi gioco le
lancette sono quattro e non due come
l'altro e in più si stacca il pavimento
quindi un casino totale
questa era la esatta questa che state
vedendo è stata la prima volta che l'ho
giocato tra l'altro quindi ero
totalmente inesperto non sapevo niente
ho detto ma penso anche gli altri perché
era appena uscito è uscita ieri e quindi
ho detto vabbè e proviamo a giocarlo
vediamo cosa succede come non so niente
io non sapranno niente neanche gli altri
quindi speriamo nel mentre crolla il
pavimento ragazzi è abbastanza semplice
evitare di andare a cadere con la cosa
che cade perché vedi trema per un'ora
poi cade mi fate in tempo a spostarvi
state solo attenti a non rimanere nella
piattaforma che rimane isolata perché
poi ce l'avete nel ca pranzi quindi
rimane che sempre nelle piattaforme dove
ci sono nella parte ci sono più
piattaforme
una volta rimasti alla fine attenzione
qua questo la parte importante una volta
rimasti alla fine l'unica cosa che manca
è continuare a saltare finché gli altri
non cadono quindi questa che la forma
non cade più dovete semplicemente
continuare a saltare e resistere più
degli altri come fare questa cosa ve la
faccio vedere allora adesso è arrivata
normalmente la lancetta che tutti quanti
a saltiamo molto easy anche questa
abbastanza easy uno anzi due si sono
fatti pregare ma ok ma saltiamo arrivati
a questo punto prestata attenzione le
lancette si sovrappongono questa qua
ragazzi e la parte difficile di jack
showdown perché se le lancette si
sovrappongono
vieri buttato giù giustamente ma se voi
saltate lo stesso anche se arrivano le
due lancette il vostro personaggio può
passare in mezzo passa proprio in mezzo
alle due lancette cosa che ho fatto io
perché se vuoi rivedere la scena
io ho saltato e gli altri non hanno
fatto niente ha detto vabbè arrivateci
colpi consultant e uguale perché ci
passate in mezzo rimanete in piedi e
vincete una partita quindi è molto
importante ragazzi non vi fate [ __ ]
dal fatto che ne arrivano due piuttosto
buttatevi usate il tasto per buttarvi
che così non saltate in verticale ma
saltate in orizzontale quindi il vostro
corpo occupa ancora meno spazio è
riuscita a passarci tranquillamente in
mezzo questa era la partita di jump
showdown molto molto [ __ ] ho preso anche
una è la terza corona che prendo su
playstation e la settima in totale gli
pareva vinto 7 volte tengo conto si sa
mai diventerò il giocatore numero nel
mondo prima di concludere ragazzi volevo
farvi vedere un paio di tricks roof
allmountain che rimane la mappa più
odiata tra tutti i giocatori di foglia
hanno fatto un sondaggio qual è la mappa
che odiate li più forma un ten è
risultata la prima c'è la mappa più
odiata in assoluto perché non si dice
mai
e inoltre non va non è meritocratica non
va a bravura ma va solo accumulo perché
all'inizio poi partire da già sei parti
davanti si è avvantaggiato all'inizio ci
può fare niente quindi l'unico modo che
ho appurato per vincere questa mappa e
ovviamente non farsi mai colpire da
niente perché come vieni colpito da
qualcosa hai praticamente perso perché
certamente data competizione che ti
basta inciampare una volta tipo questa
per perdere poi io in realtà qua non ho
perso l'ho vinta però non inciampate mai
perché come un inciampo agli altri
recuperano subito c'è troppa
competizione ragazzi quindi qua mi è
andata bene
cioè io sono inciampato la mia poi
dall'altro alla fine dovete aspettare
che la corona scenda perché sei in
saltate che la corona ancora sopra non
la prendete la presente nel ca pranzi
occhio importante ragazzi va culo
speriamo la tolgano perché la odio però
vabbè
già fatto vedere una vittoria in più chi
se ne frega quindi ragazzi quest'anno le
tattiche vi ho spiegato specialmente
sulla nuova mappa grazie del saab molto
gentile spero che vi sia piaciuto questo
non era un video normale di folgaria
ragazzi era un video spiegazione delle
nuove mappe perché so che vi interessano
queste cose ma riuscirà il video di folk
normale dove non vi spiego niente ma
giochiamo e facciamo vedere la nostra
supremazia in questo splendido gioco
quindi iscrivetevi al canale lasciate mi
piace servizio è piaciuto lasciate un
commento con le vostre tattiche con
sotto se avete delle tattiche in
particolare io me la sto cavando
abbastanza bene anzi ma giocando
benissimo realtà l'unico gioco dove
andrà cavo però i consigli sono sempre
ben accetti ragazzi quindi schede vi
pure e noi come sempre ci vediamo al
prossimo video è la ragazzi
[Musica]